diese entdeckung eines internationalen
forschungsteams sorgt wirklich für
aufregung und das nicht nur in der
fachwelt es geht um drei neue planeten
die den 31 lichtjahre entfernten stern
namens georg 357 im sternbild hydrus
kreisen auf einem der neu aufgespürten
exoplaneten könnte sogar wasser geben
möglicherweise ist er sogar bewohnbaren
diese super erde liegt quasi in unserer
direkten nachbarschaft eine reise
dorthin würde mit heutiger technik nur
einige hundert jahre dauern kriegs und
science fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierendes science videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann und nur dann verpasst
er nicht herzlich willkommen und vielen
dank für euren tollen themenvorschlag
aus unserer telegramm community von
michael klein auf tele bärn bekommt ihr
die videos früher könnte diskutieren und
themenvorschläge machen der link zu
unserem telegramm news service der ist
hier unter die da da da unter dem i und
in der video beschreibung jetzt steht
fest unsere kosmische nachbarschaft
keinen aktuellen neuzugang verzeichnen
ein internationales forschungsteam hat
nämlich jetzt einen potenziell
lebensfreundlichen planeten in unserer
nähe entdeckt es handelt sich um eine
super erde die nur 31 lichtjahre von uns
entfernt ist und das ist in
astronomischen dimensionen wirklich ein
klacks ein lichtjahr ist die strecke die
das licht in einem jahr zurücklegt der
vergleich mit unserer milchstraße macht
es deutlich ihr durchmesser beträgt etwa
100 tausend lichtjahre der neue
aufgespürte exoplaneten mit der
bezeichnung georg 357 de gehört zu einem
planeten trio das den stern mit der
bezeichnung geehrt 357 im sternbild
hydrus kreis der kreis an dritter und
äußerste planet am rand der habitablen
zone seines sterns also der zone in der
laut dem aktuellen stand der
wissenschaft leben möglich sein könnte
dazu die astronomen diana kossakowski
aus heidelberg die j 3 157 g befindet
sich am äußeren rand der bewohnbaren
zone seines sterns wo er von seinem
stern etwa die gleiche menge an stern
energie erhält wie der mars von der
sonne das bedeutet dass die sogenannte
gleichgewichts temperatur auf diesem
exoplaneten wohl bei minus 53 grad
celsius liegt mit der gleichgewichts
tempera
tourist in der fachsprache die
temperatur gemeint die sich nach einiger
zeit in einem system von selbst
einstellt angehoben werden kann sie auf
planeten beispielsweise durch den
natürlichen treibhauseffekt das
forschungsteam stellt in der aktuellen
studie die vermutung auf dass georg 357
de somit lebensfreundliche bedingungen
aufweisen könnten dazu kossakowski wenn
der planet eine dichte atmosphäre hat
könnte er genügend wärme einfangen um
den planeten zu erwärmen und flüssiges
wasser auf seiner oberfläche zuzulassen
die temperatur wäre dann durch den
treibhauseffekt der atmosphäre über null
grad celsius die genaue dichte der
atmosphäre soll jetzt schnellstmöglich
durch weitere analysen geklärt werden
dann ist natürlich noch die
zusammensetzung wichtig wir wissen ja
durch den klimawandel hier den
menschengemachten auf der erde wie wenig
co2 nötig ist um die bedingungen auf der
erde deutlich zu verschlechtern
die bisherigen berechnungen des
forschungsteams ergaben dass der
exoplanet wohl die sechsfache masse der
erde aufweist er umkreist den stern alle
55,7 tage
der abstand beträgt dabei etwa 20
prozent der entfernung zwischen sonne
und erde spektakuläre erkenntnisse die
auch die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler selbst überraschend dazu
die us astronomen lisa kaltenegger
damit ist dies die erste von tess
entdeckte supererde die leben
beherbergen könnte wenn georg 357
tatsächlich anzeichen für außerirdisches
leben zeigen sollte dann wäre diese
supererde an der spitze der künftigen
reiseziele und wir könnten endlich die
alte frage beantworten ob wir allein im
universum sind die genaue
zusammensetzung und die größe von georg
357 de sind noch unbekannt doch falls es
sich tatsächlich um eine felsige welt
mit der geschätzten masse handeln sollte
könnte man von einer 1 bis 2 fachen
größe der erde ausgehen möglich wurde
diese entdeckung mit hilfe des
weltraumteleskops trendsetting exoplanet
satellite und ehrt basierten teleskopen
test wurde erst im letzten jahr in
betrieb genommen es ist ausschließlich
dazu da exo planeten aufzuspüren mit
hilfe von teese spürte das
forschungsteam eine periodische
abdunklung der licht kurve bei dem
zwergstaat 357 auf einen hinweis darauf
dass ein planet vor dem stern
vorbeizieht
dieser verdeckt den stern in seiner
umlaufbahn teilweise und schwächt dessen
licht dadurch ab und genau das ist von
der erde aus messbar
doch diese hinweise führten nicht direkt
zur entdeckung von georg 357 de durch
die abdunklung der lichtkuppel entdeckte
das astronomie team nämlich zunächst dem
planeten geox 357 b
dieser ist ersten berechnung zufolge
etwa 22 prozent größer als die erde und
besteht höchstwahrscheinlich aus gestein
doch leben wird auf ihm wohl nicht
möglich sein dafür ist er nach ansicht
der fachleute mit einer berechneten
temperatur von etwa 250 grad celsius
viel zu heiß dennoch ist auch seine
entdeckung ein großer erfolg dazu der
astrophysiker stefan dreizler von der
universität göttingen der an der studie
beteiligt war
obwohl der planet kein leben beherbergen
kann ist er ein wichtiger meilenstein in
der erforschung erdähnliche planeten
georg 357 b ist der dritthöchste traten
sind exoplaneten und damit einer der am
besten geeigneten flächen die wir haben
um die zusammensetzung einer möglichen
atmosphäre zu messen
er ist diese entdeckung führte die
experten und expertinnen dazu den stern
und den neu entdeckten planeten einmal
genauer zu untersuchen
mit erfolg denn dabei entdeckten sie
einen weiteren exoplaneten georg 307 50
c nach berechnungen der fachleute weiß
dieser die 3,4 fache erdmasse auf die
temperatur liegt wohl bei rund 130 grad
celsius auch georg 357 c ist demnach
wohl eher nicht lebensfreundlich dann
gelang schlussendlich aber auch die
entdeckung von ge und 357 de und machte
die sensation perfekt erdähnliche
exoplaneten wurden in der vergangenheit
zuhauf ende sieben erdähnliche planeten
allein umkreisen den roten zwerg trapp
ist wann der nur 40 lichtjahre von uns
entfernt liegt bekannt ist natürlich
auch proxima centauri unser nächster
nachbar der ebenfalls von einem planeten
in der habitablen zone umkreist wird
aber auch in einer entfernung von 14
löchern befindet sich eine
lebensfreundliche supererde und diese
aufzählung ist ein jammer komplett das
internationale forschungsteam vermutet
jedenfalls dass es einen weiteren
vierten planeten gibt er den sternen
geber 357 umkreis auch dieser soll jetzt
noch aufgespürt werden auch wenn das nun
entdeckte planetensystem astronomisch
gesehen in unserem
direkt mehr liegt geht das
internationale forschungs 7 nicht davon
aus dass wir menschen es in naher
zukunft bereisen oder gar besiedeln
könnten mit der technik der voyager
sonden würde eine reise dorthin einige
hundert jahre dauern neue studie zeigt
außerirdisches leben könnte ganz nahe
sein darüber berichtet neugier zone
unbedingt anklicken anschauen und
neugier zone abonnieren hammer kanal bis
dann bleibt dran